a certain influencer um lost her father
you read the caption over here
butterfly fly away
okay
rip pappy
you were my best friend
a life well lived rip happy veteran ptsd
funeral never forgotten cool now take a
look at the picture uh three
three messages no no the picture the
picture of her
bro
you really had me
oh
no
i don't know how the [ __ ] you did it
but that
i really listen to the task so i really
just read the caption didn't pay
attention to nothing
none of it nothing i just went out i
just wanted
and then you show me the rest
is she posing in front of the cats
getting bigger
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh you ain't [ __ ] for this one
oh you did that
i couldn't believe it when i seen it
oh
there's always some cringe people that
film the casket i take pictures of the
casket like what are you doing
this
is another level we just see the picture
uh-huh but i just feel like okay take
another one okay take another one yes
okay hold on hold on hold on wait
that's what i think about you imagine
the photographer's like watch out don
don't knock over the casket he's [ __ ]
dead who cares
he's dead what's gonna happen okay we'll
always remember you daddy it's like oh
while he passed on i won't pass on this
opportunity oh my
god yeah so so here's so you know we
clowned her but here's a more serious
take right oh first
listen i think we all grieve in
different ways i think
some dude by laughing that
no no
i'm sorry
one thing that i've liked about
traveling is i've seen people celebrate
death and weird ways some people have
parades some people dance at funerals
some people cry solemnly some people
have to be quiet some people observe
and take a vow silence for a bit
the way people process death is vastly
different
but
when
your experience is more concerned
with the validation of strangers online
when you use someone else's passing
as social currency for yourself i think
then we enter area where it's starting
to understand just how much
how much being observed shapes people
and it kind of destroys any form of
ritual or sanctity or anything like that
you know um
so
so there's that difficult aspect the
other side that i would say is
when i see this you might be shocked you
might be like oh my god how do we get
here all this other stuff in my head
this is just inevitable you know after
you get over the initial shock it's like
man people are out here filming they're
giving birth people out here filming
death people out here filming crime
documenting crime people are out here
doing all kinds of crazy pranks
themselves which result in their own
deaths
people document everything for social
currency so i don't know why a funeral
or death would be any different in that
sense we don't hold anything sacred
that's this for most people
so this seems inevitable and for someone
like her who lives off of this right
social currency who lives online and on
instagram
and who's always rewarded for
documenting her life
true
whatever its gratification or
right you know like we as society also
have to accept that we manufacture this
by constantly rewarding people for
sharing every detail of their lives
whether it be reality tv or whatever it
is we create an environment where it's
like
share your pain right we we love when
people share their pain you have
something terrible happen to you get
online like we encourage that society so
this kind of behavior to me just seems
inevitable that's what i thought when i
saw it what were your thoughts well to
me it's just like what would you talk
about people like and they're rewarded
when they share their pain it just all
started with all those dance shows that
these [ __ ] cannot just dance
right they have to cry well they have to
have a background they have to have a
backstory that makes people want to cry
and want to believe in them oh it's the
underdog that undercame whatever
and it gets really heavy it's not even
about talent no more it's about who
struggled the most you know what i mean
so
it's like what someone cannot just be
good at dance and their life be good you
know what i mean no it has to be like
yeah my mama had this my daddy had that
uh my whole family for taking me and
this and that but you know what i got no
legs but i was able to overcome and be
the you know i mean like it's always a
sob story
yeah you see it in the media it's like
we love drama and i don't remember who
said that and the person who said that
was an interview with charlemagne the
god
social media is although i don't believe
in any of that crap there is some basis
to you know the seven deadly sins
okay uh
social media is based on that it's based
on all the social media that you watch
is either going to be one of the seven
deadly
what sins
going to cater to that it's going to be
that we're going to see either it's
going to be with greed either it's going
to be with anger if it's going to be
with envy some some of that is going to
be like and then it's just
one of the sins it's that's what it is
you have to understand that that's what
it is
it's fueled by that by all of that so at
some point yeah sometimes i
get away from that i refrain from always
posting everything that i do with
everybody that i'm with if i go into the
restaurant you best believe i shut the
[ __ ] up and i eat i'm not gonna take a
picture oh this is what happened no no
broadcasting all of that is weird to me
in every aspect of my life if i if if i
got to do something about my job that's
one thing but my personal life i don't
know i'm not really comfortable posting
all of that stuff out there
for what and for who and who wants to
know and why would you know you
understand what i'm saying it's like
being too accessible and [ __ ] so yeah
yeah but nowadays folks are accessible
all the time that's why you have
internet on your phone all day long
people can always know where you are
your gps location is often given to your
friends and family yeah right people are
documented people are literally live
streaming their lives they're doing 36
hour streams or 10 hour streams where
they're just with people online all the
time we reward people
for documenting their happy moments
their breakups their drama so
even funerals are not safe anymore
nothing is
nothing is sacred soon i promise you
once it's legal
they'll be live streaming like giving
birth no find a way to shove a camera up
a girl's uterus and just you want to see
what's going on with the with the baby i
think i think this is the future i think
uh this is
you should expect more of this
and um
yeah if it upsets you i completely get
it for me i had that same reaction but
looking at it a whole holistic little
bit of the whole thing it's just
we're gonna get more of this oh yeah and
it's not
hey you know what's crazy is that for
her if she'd kept her instagram up you
know beyond all the threats and stuff
she probably would have gained a few
thousand followers
people because no matter how disgusted
and outraged people are there's going to
be a huge segment of folks who are like
oh she's got to own fence oh what other
dead bodies did she pose besides you
know like people are going to take an
interest yeah definitely yeah the order
they're going to follow you just to see
what the next stupid [ __ ] you're going
to be doing yeah people like stupid [ __ ]
what you're saying the father what the
father is a veteran who went to uh i
believe it's like uh i'm pretty sure
it's vietnam so she was like posting
about how like oh my father's a veteran
thank you for your service and you just
got her in the background like jeez
went to war
yeah
i started vietnam killed it
on fleek hashtag veteran ashtaq veteran
and hashtag on fleek should not be next
to each other yeah check out these guns
not my father's guns what do you guys
think about this what do you think this
says about society and as a whole i know
a lot of you are going to be in there in
the comments and be like oh [ __ ]
you know jesus is coming or whatever you
know
well what do you guys think all right
let us know i think it's great